[Music]
you are amazing Golden Globe nomination
how did you celebrate how'd you hear I'm
celebrating with releasing Jumanji the
Jumanji premiere it feels like the
perfect fitting day I'm really actually
going for the best day ever
I woke up at 6:00 a.m. to the news I was
freaking out running around my room like
a ten year old kid and then to be here
tonight to celebrate this film I can
combine it all feels really good it's a
few points today I'd literally pinched
myself I've heard people say that my
entire life I never actually did it I'm
something going this has to be a dream
but it's not I really so it feels
amazing and I'm just I'm blown away
what did your brothers think about the
nomination would it they say well I
don't think they even knew I was in
contention so they were like wait wait
wait what I called them both right away
when I found out the news and my parents
got on FaceTime my mom was crying it was
a sweet moment yeah best message you got
all day best message I got all day I
think it was from my brother Joe just
you know proud of me and and those
moments where life sort of stops for a
moment and one of these things yet but
look at your brother it was he's here
tonight but he grabbed the back of my
head he said listen I love you I'm proud
of you this is a big moment enjoy
tonight felt good
I'm out watch your step in here so
gnarly how much fun is it being a part
of this and this crazy crew it's
unbelievable I mean my first day on set
was after they'd already been shooting
for about a week and the the energy the
warmth that they created on set start
with Dwayne and Kevin and Jack and Karen
I mean they are consummate professionals
and truly brilliant what they do and I
think the energy you've you felt on set
comes through in the film it's a movie
about friendship adventure and it's a
lot of laughs in it and it all works in
a great way
[Music]